let's bring in Pete hag Seth Fox and
Friends Weekend co-host and author of a
book on the education situation in this
country and Leo Terrell constitutional
attorney and Fox News contributor he's
also a former High School teacher Leah
let me start with you you went through
this study uh saw the Wall Street
Journal in-depth piece that they wrote
on it what's the biggest concern that
you have when you look at what happened
here
uh total crickets by the union Martha
this is devastating let me be very clear
these kids can never make this up what I
also saw was the disparity between those
who were on the lower end of this
spectrum particularly minorities people
of color
these kids schools should have never
been closed Martha and Randy Weingarten
and the union representative they use
these kids as pawns these two years of
education they lost they'll never get
them back so what I find disingenuous is
they use the covet as a pretext of the
safest kids in the world were the kids
if they stayed at school and we lost
those years and the quality of education
is so important and we still have a
mayor in Washington D.C who still thinks
the pandemic is still going on it is
tragedy as a person of color it's it's
heart-wrenching because education is a
civil rights issue and the school
district and the unions and the extreme
left use these kids as pawns and they
lost their education
Pete I cannot understand where the
outrage is remember Randy weingarten's
outrage at people suggesting that the
schools should be reopened she'd come on
I I interviewed her several times during
that period oh we don't have the
resources we don't have the resources we
can't possibly remember the teachers in
front with the body bags and cemeteries
you know saying if you make us go back
you're going to kill us where is the
passion around this issue take a look at
the allocation 122 billion dollars of
the hard-earned taxpayer money that went
to covet relief was allocated to our
schools they haven't spent 87 and a half
percent on it so why did we hear so much
screaming about resources if they
weren't going to address the problem
Pete
well our assumption is that it was all
about kids and I agree with everything
Leo just said this is about power and
control
for unions why did that where did that
money go to instead a lot of it went to
diversity Equity inclusion counselors at
and more woke aspects of Education as
opposed to getting kids in school this
ultimately should shock nobody and it
was not to point the finger at trump it
was the Trump White House that was
trying to get the teachers in the
schools the American
okay
yeah
Pediatrics let's just get I'm sorry so
here's what he said a few weeks after
POTUS put measures in place a majority
of schools were open for the first time
since the pandemic started but we are
not finished the board of uh Department
of Education has more to do now we have
to repair the Damage Done by Donald
Trump's mismanagement of the pandemic
that was the first tweet that Cardona
sent out when he got this report he has
since softened that language a little
bit in the statement that they put out
I'm sorry Pete go ahead
no false false false gaslighting they
browbeat the Trump Administration
attempted to get the unions to do it
worked hard with the Academy of
patriotics Pediatrics in fact the
pediatrics group wanted to open the
schools and the unions put so much
pressure on them they reversed course
the kids were never vulnerable they were
never threatened this was about unions
and you know it's dead you saw a lot of
these School boards renaming schools one
in Minnesota my home state Patrick Henry
High School oh it's been renamed and
it's the best school in Minneapolis but
only 65 percent of ninth graders can
read at grade level and that's the best
school the average in Minneapolis 36
percent reading at grade level what
about the kids who are nine in this
study when they're ninth grade yeah I
can't even believe this is the United
States of America Leo I I can't believe
it when I look at these numbers this is
a country that has always prided itself
on our public education system and we're
talking about scores that are 215 out of
a a range of zero to 500 and we're
supposed to be we're supposed to be okay
with even a seven point drop that takes
it to 215
we lost 20 years of quality education in
those three years of of where the the
unions and the the strategy was to keep
kids at home they didn't get education
the school teachers loved it Martha they
loved it and I was on your show and I
broke down like a crybaby when when the
collateral damage the kids who lost
their interaction with kids they the the
human loss the mental loss the mental
anguish of kids who couldn't go to
school and they were depressed and you
did shows on that this is it falls at
the hands of the Union as a former
school teacher I'm telling you I'm sick
by this we the three of us represent the
benefits of a quality education these
kids lost quality education and they'll
never get it back Martha you know I
think about President Biden who stands
up at a lot of these appearances and
talks about guns and other issues that
he's very passionate about and that's
his that's his prerogative and he says
what are we doing here
and I'm thinking where is where does he
stand up and look at this look at this
and say what are we doing here his wife
Dr Jill Biden Doctorate in Education
this should be front of mind they should
say every teacher is going to be
measured on how they get their students
caught up and we're going to be looking
at every one of you and we're going to
be measuring your performance and making
sure that you get those kids to read
reading level because our nine-year-olds
are suffering uh and it's going to be
all up and down the line when we see the
bigger numbers uh it's just it's just an
absolute and every parent should have
the power to choose the money should
follow them so that schools compete for
them I don't say this lightly we should
not be proud of our Public School System
anymore of our government-run school
system and I'm a product of public
schools they have failed our kids not
just in the basics not just in the
basics but now in extreme indoctrination
racist policies gender policies at the
youngest of Ages so one of the bonuses
is they were in school for two years at
least they weren't being taught to
change their gender that's what we've
come to at this point parents need to
wake up seek a choice and politicians
should seek to give them that choice
only competition choice and options will
will liberate kids and the most
vulnerable kids from the grip of unions
who just want to rip more money and are
never held to account for their
standards and we wonder why we're seeing
what we're seeing in the cities and
younger and younger kids getting
involved in crime situations on the
Subways it's it's heartbreaking
absolutely heartbreaking but they've
been let go out of the system 50 000
kids didn't show up for the first day of
school in Los Angeles now some of them
transferred to other schools some of
them are probably gone forever from our
education system and that's on all of us
that's on this whole country and
dropping the ball and selling our kids
short so I know that you both feel very
strongly about this Leo thank you very
much great to have you with us we'll
continue to dig in on this thank you hi
winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now